it gives me great pleasure to introduce
David gross 2004 Nobel laureate in
physics and professor of physics at
their Caverly Institute of experimental
physics in Santa Barbara to give us a
talk on truth and the scientific method
David
so I must start by correcting the line
you just heard I'm both the cover the
Institute for Theoretical Physics and
I'm going to talk to to a receptive
audience about truth in the scientific
method so in preparing this talk I too
like the previous speaker asked the
question what is truth and looking at
the dictionaries I found the coil as
Simon explained the correspondence
theory of truth truth is the quality or
state of being true or truth is that
that is true or in accordance with fact
or reality and what is true well it is
agreeing with fact not false or wrong so
this is a Gordian knot and we've heard a
bit of the oesophagus cushon about what
is truth and is there such a absolute
notion I'm going to try to as a
theoretical physicist cut through the
Gordian knot and simply define truth as
that that is revealed by the scientific
method that's a that's a strong
statement and I should say a word about
what the scientific method is I believe
it's humankind's greatest invention it's
rather new only four hundred years old
it rests on the assumption the belief
the tentative hypothesis that the world
of observable phenomena is real and
intelligible it can be made sense of in
a collective manner subject to the
requirements of logic and consistency
and based on observation and
experimentation and traditionally we
think of the scientific method as
consisting of three components
observation experiment and theory
early science is largely observational
and as that improves and we understand
what phenomena exists out there in a
grow in a increasingly precise fashion
we can do quantitative experiments
probing the nature of those phenomena
and using theoretical models and
mathematical tools we can try to explain
and model those experimental findings
suggest new experiments make predictions
that test our theories and explanations
and that approach the why questions what
how and why is a normal progression of
science this scientific method yields
explanations and phenomena that can be
explained and produces very importantly
and perhaps that's the driving force
behind the evolution of science over the
centuries increases our control and
leads to up important applications that
society appreciates it as willing to
sponsor more scientific research but
from the point of view of science the
increase in control and applications of
our understanding immediately feedback
onto observation in an experiment
allowing us to improve our methods of
collecting data and explore in the
universe now the scientific method
produces science and I'm trying to argue
in a way that science is if you want the
best candidate for what truth is and if
we want to explore what we mean in a
precise and powerful way by truth we
could replace interchange and I will do
so science and truth at will truth or
science has certain characteristics as I
said before
science or scientific truth is based on
observation experimentation and
theoretical constructs its findings
facts and theories are continuously
subject to the requirements of logic
consistency and reproducibility it is
always tentative and must subjected
standards to experimental tests the only
judge of the validity of our insights is
nature but as popper emphasized and
Fineman expressed we are never
definitely right we are can only be sure
when we are that we are wrong nature can
disprove our ideas our predictions our
theories it can never prove them it's
only that's them survived and from a
practical point of view the working
hypothesis of a of a scientist is that
we're on the right track or our
tentative truths are correct or we have
belief in them when it works the nature
of scientific truth is very special and
has certain aspects that have that
underlay the Enlightenment and the
growth of democracy since science and
the pursuit of the scientific method
require an open transparent non
authoritarianism its creators it might
be created by a scientist who is then
rewarded with prizes and awards but the
created truth belongs to everyone
and to no one science is universal it is
intended and it applies everywhere and
to everyone it knows no boundaries
science scientific truth lacks all
Authority save nature and all are equal
in its pursuit we in science respect the
ideas and are willing to subject them to
tests of anyone and science finally is
always bathed in ignorance it admits to
ignorance to lack of knowledge about the
boundaries of our knowledge its truth is
always tentative and subject to strength
to change the strength of science is
clear it has survived and grown over and
it survived its many enemies over the
last 400 years partly because truth has
the inherent strength of being true
in addition science has other sources of
strength and resiliency Philip Anderson
once remarked that science is a multiple
connected web that is a feature that is
a great source of stability in addition
I would argue that the AI reductionist
nature of fundamental science which has
been expanded and confirmed over the
centuries is also a great source of
strengthening this web of truth thus one
cannot argue that the co2 emissions do
not cause global warming without
contradicting the truth of physical
chemistry and thus the truths of quantum
theory of atoms and the whole web of
fundamental physics truth is not always
convenient
science does have limitations we should
recognize those there are questions that
currently at least cannot be addressed
by observation by experiment or by
theory by the scientific method these
include questions like why is there
something rather than nothing or what is
the meaning of life but other questions
there were once thought to be outside
the domain of science such as what is
life and what is the history of the
universe are now part of science and
addressable by the scientific method
physical cosmology today seeks to
address a question how did the universe
begin previously left to religion and
philosophy now the challenge for science
especially in today's world is great the
search for truth can be full of pitfalls
scientists are fallible human beings
people who are susceptible to bias
conscious and unconscious and indeed the
scientific method requires policing to
make cheating difficult and to protect
to protect one from unconscious bias we
are continually trying to perfect these
methods perfect our instruments and our
observations and improve statistical
tools but therefore scientists correctly
admit to uncertainty and are generally
very careful and cautious in their
conclusions and predictions and this can
produce confusion outside of science
where such restraint is uncommon even as
the basis for pronouncements is less
reliable
how are we to convey to enumerate
society that many facts theories and
predictions having passed through the
strong filter of the scientific method
are highly reliable while at the same
time retaining uncertainty and
tentativeness to put it more bluntly how
are we to compete with liars it's an
unfair fight we come to this fight with
rules of behavior that the other side
often does not accept and this is a
question to the rest of the day I would
love to hear the answer to this how can
scientific truth compete with liars who
don't accept the rules of the game I am
an optimist and I truly believe that
scientific truth will prevail science
has survived both earth Pope Urban the
eighth's
attack on Galileo and as Copernican
ideas science survived
Stalin's attack on Darwinism science
survived
Hitler's attack on Jewish science and
Einstein and science will survive Donald
J Trump and his ilk truth will triumph
thank you